ils appellent à la révolution
démocratique bruno le maire ancien
ministre ump de l'agriculture est notre
invité bonsoir bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous pour ce rendez vous réalisez
comme chaque semaine en partenariat avec
l' agence france-presse
et dailymotion est déj que jacques
d'ailleurs puis perrine tarneaud de
public sénat
nous rejoindrons bruno le maire pour
vous interroger bien d'abord sur ce
renouveau complet que vous réclamez à
l'ump
vous voulez être vous même un nouveau
visage une nouvelle voie évidemment et
puis sur cette moralisation des
pratiques politiques qui vous préconisez
il ya des sujets d'actualité sur
lesquels on a envie de vous entendre par
exemple les primes en liquide que
s'était octroyé cloud guillaume face à
elle c'est pour plus tard dans
l'émission d'abord l'actualité c'est
l'hommage de françois hollande à pierre
mauroy pour le premier premier ministre
de gauche de la vème république et
réformer ce n'était pas renoncer
c'était réussir selon les mots du
président de la république bon jusque là
vous êtes d'accord évidemment non non
non je n'ai pas renoncé c'est réussir
wii la wii sur l'airé cela si on
s'arrête là oui et je partage l'hommage
qui a été rendu à la personnalité de
pierre mauroy qui était une personnalité
attachante et éminemment respectable en
revanche quand on regarde ses réformes
ça a été un échec complet et je crois
que nous devons avoir la lucidité de
dire que tous les choix qui ont été
faits entre 1981 et 1983 sont des choix
qui seront respectable mais qui ne sont
pas les miens et qui ont mis la france
en grande difficulté économique vous
pensé quand je pense à la durée du
travail je pense que c'était partir du
mauvais pied c'était mettre la france du
mauvais pied il ya aujourd'hui près de
30 ans plus tard nous en payons encore
les conséquences et nous devons faire
repartir la france du bon pied je crois
que c'est la responsabilité de ma
famille politique dans l'opposition de
proposer justement un projet
radicalement différent quand j'en vois
qui disent c'était formidable mauroy 81
l'homme est formidable la politique
qu'il a menée avant lui un échec complet
et nous en payons encore aujourd'hui les
conséquences en france nous devons nous
la droite proposer une alternative
radicalement différent est-ce que vous
tim et que françois hollande qui a lancé
donc une nouvelle réforme des retraites
aurait dû éviter de rappeler
l'abaissement de l'âge de départ
moi je me rends ou plus du tout et
françois hollande je ne me retrouve plus
du tout il arrive au pouvoir
et il remet la retraite à 60 ans pour un
certain nombre de français avec un
second temps qui est très élevé ensuite
quelques mois après il vient revoir
toujours les mêmes français vous et moi
tous les téléspectateurs pour leur dire
voilà la réforme des retraites elle est
absolument indispensable
on ne peut plus financer aujourd'hui
notre régime de retraite dont qui dit
exactement le contraire et il engage
actuellement une réforme des retraites
qui est à mon avis sera la fois injuste
et inefficace
et puis on al'occasion pas encore les
détails à attendre et attendre et on
attend au bout dit en effet je suis prêt
à la voter
la d'organisations dont elle l'occasion
de l'hommage à pierre mauroy
tout d'un coup on revient sur la
retraite à 60 ans passés vraiment la
politique de gribouille
on peut pas quand on est chef de l'état
dire tout et son contraire
or françois hollande dit tout et son
contraire on peut pas dire un matin la
retraite 60 ans c'est formidable dit
pierre mauroy et je la remets à 60 ans
pour plusieurs milliers de personnes et
dire l'après midi il faut de réforme des
retraites massive reporter l'âge légal
ou allonger la durée de cotisation parce
que sinon le système on peut plus
financer rosé fond saphir trouve à damas
affirmant sur cette question
particulière et mauvaise augure pour la
réforme est annoncée jolie trouver
maladroit parce que nouvelle fois on a
l'impression d'un écran de fumée et je
crois que s'il qui inquiète aujourd'hui
les français ce qui explique le climat
de défiance profond qui touche tous les
français les familles et les pme les
artisans les commerçants
ce qui fait qu aucune entreprise n'a
investi plus que plus personne n'a
confiance c'est que ils voient tous un
chef de l'état qui les ont fumé qui sait
pas où il va qui dit une chose le matin
le contraire le soir vive la retraite à
60 ans le matin il faut allonger de
votre cotisation de choix personne ne
s'y retrouve et ça crée forcément une
anxiété profond de la société française
vous avez entendu aussi françois
hollande dire à propos de pierre mauroy
qu'il avait assumé des décisions
difficiles n'y a pas eu que la retraite
à 60 ans
les 39 heures hebdomadaires il ya eu
aussi le gel des prix des des salaires
et donc il y avait quand même aussi un
éloge de la rigueur dans la bouche du
chef de l'état ça vous l'avez entendu
aussi j'ai entendu une fois en cours des
choses totalement contraire à dimanche
je voudrais savoir c'est quelle est le
cap de françois hollande prenez
l'exemple de la réforme des retraites
moi j'ai dit qu'effectivement je serai
prêt à voter avec l'actuelle majorité
une réforme des retraites qui s'appuie
sur trois piliers très simple le premier
c'est l'alignement des règles du public
sur les règles du privé je ne vois pas
pourquoi on calculerait sur la base des
six derniers mois dans un cas sur la
base des 25 dernières années dans un
autre que ce soit la même règle pour
tous le même régime de retraite pour
tous
deuxième élément qui me paraît
absolument essentiel c'est que l'on
supprime tous les régimes spéciaux
troisième élément que nous ayons un
report de l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite
on verra on peut en discuter mais il est
évident qu'à partir du moment où nous
vivons plus longtemps
nous devons tous travailler plus
longtemps et sont légalisés propose
également un régime par points
parce que je pense que pour chacun pour
s'y retrouver c'est plus simple d'avoir
un régime par points plutôt que l'actuel
régime sur l'égalité des systèmes
publics-privés il y à un certain nombre
de catégories de personnels comme les
contrôleurs il ya par exemple qui
partent des 52 emplois parler des
cheminots et les pompiers les policiers
et arrière scène c'est à la sncf vous
voulez aussi aligné tout le monde là sur
la même date de départ
qu'est ce qui justifie que un certain
nombre de catégories du secteur public
et des avantages en matière de retraites
si on arrive à me prouver que c'est
juste c'est la fameuse pénibilité
semble-t-il qui existe a dit que ces
départs anticipés pour celsus déjà allé
dans un abattoir
vous avez vu ce que c'est que le travail
d'un ouvrier qui est à la chaîne dans
une usine d'abattage porcin et bovin
vous avez vu la pénibilité du travail
si vous êtes déjà allé dans les hauts
fourneaux avaient vu la pénibilité du
travail dans les hauts fourneaux que
dans les usines de laminage n'a une chez
moi à breteuil-sur-iton dans mon
département
ça c'est des boulots qui sont pénibles
et qui sont difficiles à vous comprenez
pas la langue
finalement pour un traitement la
paysanne aux pieds qui sont confrontés à
des métiers ancêtres indivisibilité ça
me paraît un prix commenceraient
important d'une réforme juste pour ceux
qui comme un coq en des métiers qui sont
physiquement pénible qui sont durs avec
des espérances de vie qui sont
objectivement existe aussi dans la
fonction mais qui n'est ça ne doit être
que dans les exécutions par rapport à
une règle et la red ça doit être le même
régime de retraite pour tous publics
privés alignement total régimes spéciaux
on les supprime un seul régime de
retraites cor c'est clair mais c'est
très important le point sur les départs
anticipés et voulait supprimer aussi je
supprime aussi les départs anticipés de
la fonction publique qui ne répondent à
aucune motivation que peuvent comprendre
les français en équité et en justice on
s'est parlé réalisée juste c'est que ce
qui effectivement des travaux qui sont
réellement pénible il y en a ça existe
on doit en tenir compte la pénibilité
qui ont été ouvertes avec eric woerth je
crois que c'est une vraie avancée
il faut en tenir compte donc vous
n'oubliez pas certaines inégalités avec
le public contre le privé où la 20e et
vous savez ni billy télétravail les un
jour de droite ne sont pas d'horribles
tortionnaires qui veulent le mal des
pauvres gens qui travaillent et frère
chacun aime à le préciser
moi je veux la justice pas les tenir que
les gens qui sont dans le privé les gens
qui sont dans le public puisse se dire
il ya plus qu'un seul régime de retraite
en france par point avec des cotisations
progressiste qui permettent à chacun de
s'y retrouver mais on arrête avec les
avantages on arrête avec tout ce qu'ils
sont des privilèges aux yeux des
français et on tient compte en revanche
du caractère pénible un certain nombre
de métiers dont je reconnais très
volontiers qu'il mérite d'être pris en
compte et là on peut partir à 60 ans ça
tout peut-être bien là et c'était le
centre ville soit la première réforme ce
sujet ont peut-être misrata mais une
vraie refondation des retraites le point
de départ le point de départ c'est légal
issus l'équité l'égalité
les socialistes que ce mot à la bouche
égalité et bien qu'ils fassent l'égalité
dans les régimes public et les régimes
privés la sphère mich
avec les suppressions d'emplois à
joué-lès-tours montre-t-elle qu'en
france on ne peut gagner en
compétitivité qu'en supprimant des
emplois
je crois qu'on pourrait industrialisés
la france je crois sincèrement que
l'industrie qui représente aujourd'hui
environ 12% du produit national brut
alors qu'on était à 15 ou 17 % et encore
quelques années nous pouvons revenir à
20% en l'espace de quelques années si
nous prenons les décisions difficiles
nécessaires si nous nous allégeons les
charges qui pèsent sur les salaires et
que nous avons un autre financement de
la protection sociale nous pourrons
réindustrialiser le pays
si nous sommes capables de dégager une
vraie profitabilité pour les entreprises
industrielles pour qu'elles puissent
ensuite investir innover avant des
produits que c'est toujours la meilleure
qualité nous pourrons industrialisés si
nous apprenons à travailler ensemble des
laboratoires de recherche les centres
d'innovation les industries les grandes
entreprises industrielles avec les
chercher temps et les menuiseries nice
il vaut dit il faut prendre des mesures
définies pour varier nos ensembles en
effet comme une mesure difficile pour
les français ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire financés autrement notre protection
sociale
ça veut dire accepter que nous
réduisions et dépenses sociales ça veut
dire accepter d'augmenter le taux de tva
pour arriver à avoir un autre
financement de la protection sociale
ça veut dire simplifier le droit du
travail pour qu'une entreprise
industrielle qui a un carnet de
commandes qui tout d'un coup augmente
parce que la conjoncture est bonne
puisque recruté très rapidement et puis
lorsque le carnet de commandes est moins
bon puisse se séparer temporairement de
ses salles à il fallait pas le sens
justement de la loi sur la sécurisation
de l'emploi que françois hollande a fait
voter et qu'il présente comme une
avancée un premier pas mais sympa
totalement j'ai d'ailleurs certains se
demandent qu'à gauche notamment si le
plan social qui est annoncé chez
michelin mais pas la préfiguration de
cette loi sur la sécurisation de
l'emploi qui a été voté par la cfdt on
d'année par la cgt enfin comment est ce
que l'on peut dire ça ça c'est les
billevesées est très franchement le plan
social bien entendu que je regrette
profondément qu on en arrive là
il est bien entendu que je partage la
détresse des salariés qui se retrouvent
sans aucun possibilités de reclassement
pour le moment qui se demandent de quoi
leur avenir va être refait mais c'est
aussi le fruit du manque de courage que
nous avons eu tous tous
beaucoup des dernières années le rapport
en l'espèce je vous difficile et en
espèces la direction met chacun fait
preuve de courage selon vous je
qualifierais pas de courage un plan
social
très franchement le courage il doit être
du côté des politiques n'auront jamais
courage de prendre des décisions
difficiles aujourd'hui pour amuser dire
de ma décision courageuse c'est aussi la
pad à sa politique se posait la question
du principe de précaution est ce qu'il
est bon que nous gardions le principe de
précaution dans la constitution
moi je crois que l'on pourrait
avantageusement le remplacer par un
principe de responsabilité
regardez sur les gaz de schiste en mode
réaction d'innovation mais regardez sur
les gaz de schiste qu'est ce que l'on
fait est ce que l'on ferme immédiatement
la porte à toute recherche les gaz de
schiste parce qu'on estime que c'est
trop dangereux
mais dans ce cas là effectivement on ne
va pas réindustrialiser le pays c'est ce
qui a permis la réalisation des
occasions où est-ce qu'au contraire on
autorise la recherche dans les
conditions encadré avec les précautions
nécessaires et avec ce principe de
responsabilité c'est à dire celui qui
recherche le gaz de schiste devient
responsable de sa décision
je pense qu'un principe de
responsabilité plutôt qu'un principe de
précaution c'est aussi un des éléments
de leur industrie est descendu place un
mot quand même raynaud la mer vous qui
avez été à matignon avec dominic vaile
neuville pas vous attaquez totem du
du chiraquisme là le principe de
précaution qui l'a fait entrer dans la
constellation est je pense avoir dit
suffisamment doit se réinventer
la droite doit se réinventer totalement
en regardant ce qu'elle a réussi ce
qu'elle n'a pas réussi en matière
industrielle
les cheminots du chiraquisme alors qu'il
est tellement difficile en tant que
leader de l'ump de faire le bilan des
dix années que j'ai passées moi-même au
pouvoir de 2002 à 2012 et dont j'assume
tout le bilan tout mais avec aussi une
lucidité qui me paraît indispensable
pour dire mais ce que nous avons tous
réussi non est-ce que la
réindustrialisation du pays elle est là
non est-ce que nous souffrons tous la
disparition des emplois industriels
oui est ce que notre agriculture est
menacée d'agriculture d'octobre de
production de l'élevage ou du lait oui
les majorités sur elle
donc nous devons impérativement être
capable de réinventer notre doctrine de
droite et dans cette réinvention de
latrines de droite
je considère que la question du principe
de précaution doit être posée sachant
qu'elle a été présentée encore une fois
par la droite comme une protection des
consommateurs que nous sommes aussi mais
ça nous a pas échappé tous ont perdu les
élections
donc si nous avions tous réussis je
pourrais vous dire ce soir gardons tous
nous avons tous réussis dont notre
politique était la bonne et rien à
corriger
moi je vous dis le contraire très bien
je vous dis nous avons perdu les
élections parce que nous ne sommes pas
allés au bout de nos idées au bout de
nos convictions et que sur un certain
nombre de points comme le maintien des
capacités productives en france
industrielle ou agricole
il aurait sans doute fallu aller
beaucoup plus loin voilà c'est clair et
net sur un certain nombre de sujets vous
l'avez exprimé sur les retraites sur le
principe de précaution et sur les
mesures difficiles
puis vous vous les présenter aux
français qui sont nécessaires pour voilà
on va évoquer avec nadège fils jacques d
agence france presse
la situation à l'ump je le disais tout à
l'heure à vous n'êtes pas tendre avec
vos amis invités à changer du tout au
tout et a abandonné le culte du chef
mathieu bélanger
nicolas sarkozy reviendra si l'on a
besoin de lui
c'est en tout cas ce qu'il aurait
déclaré la semaine dernière lors d'une
conférence à londres
de quoi alimenter de nouveau les
spéculations sur son retour
à l'ump certains commencent à s'en
agacer est ce que vous pourriez laisser
nicolas sarkozy en paix voilà le laisser
décider de son propre avenir
d'après une décision courageuse il ya un
an maintenant le fait un très beau
discours en expliquant qu' quitter la
vie politique
laissons libre de son choix l'ump peut
pas passer trois ou quatre années d'ici
2017 à attendre de voir si la statue du
commandeur on va bouger
voilà l'opposition ce n'est pas cela ça
n'est pas que la critique du
gouvernement ainsi même si c'est facile
en ce moment ça doit être aussi la
construction d'un projet mais si la page
a tant de mal à se tourner c'est que
depuis la défaite à la présidentielle
l'ump est un parti sans chef
le duel fillon copé le feuilleton des
élections internes n'ont pas réglé la
question du leadership
tout le monde s'accorde à dire qu'il
faudra attendre la primaire de 2016 pour
trancher
on a au sein de l'ump des personnalités
très différentes porteurs de messages
assez différent il ya un problème de
clarification de la ligne politique ça
je pense que c'est une certitude
et c'est plutôt là dessus que les
français nous attendent l'ump reste
profondément divisée sur certaines
questions comme l'attitude à adopter
face au front national
le débat sur le mariage pour tous a lui
aussi tracer des lignes de fracture sans
compter que le parti n'a toujours pas
fait l'inventaire du quinquennat sarkozy
il n'est pas possible de faire un droit
d'inventaire pour reprendre la formule
jospin ce sens que le chef précédent et
pris sa retraite ou été explicitement
éliminé par un nouveau chef
ni l'un ni l'autre cas ne s'est produit
et donc l'inventaire n'est pas possible
en attendant jean françois copé a
prévenu qu'il n'y aurait pas de
traitement de faveur pour l'ancien
président s'il revient il devra comme
les autres passer par la case primaire
son chef
on va voir pas trop vite alors vous
employez souvent monsieur le maire
l'expression il faut dire la vérité aux
français et vous accusez françois
hollande d'ailleurs de leur mentir par
exemple quand il leur dit qu'il va
inverser la courbe du chômage avant la
fin de l'année mais l'ump dans votre
parti il y a des voix discordantes sur
de nombreux sujets les manifestations
contre le mariage homosexuel l'europe le
cumul des mandats même vous êtes contre
le cumul dans cette polyphonie
qu'est ce qui dit la vérité à l'ump ce
qu'on nous apprendre que tout à fait
nouveau pour nous c'est vivre avec
effectivement un parti qui n'a pas un
leader naturel mais qui a plusieurs
personnalités très différentes qui
s'expriment de manière différente sur un
certain nombre de sujets je crois pas
que ce soit un problème si nous
respectons un certain nombre de règles
ces règles c'est ne pas se critiquer
personnellement ne pas se livrer à des
attaques de bataille des batailles d'ego
c'est apporter sa contribution à la
définition d'une doctrine commune et
c'est en troisième lieu se battre pour
gagner les élections municipales de 2014
élections européennes de 2014 mais ça
n'est pas un problème qu'il y est à mon
sens plusieurs personnalités fortes à
l'ump alors tiré au monde devront
décider sur les primaires c'est la
première fois notre vie politique à
droite que nous faisons des primaires va
forcément ça change la donne et moi ma
conviction c'est que vous ne ferez pas
émerger un leader naturel avant les
primaires de 2016 puisque les prières de
2016 sont précisément là pour le
départager ce leader falloir attendre 3
ans et l'on suppose justement habituer
parce que vous avez
à partir du moment où on sait cela ça
doit nous conduire à une discipline de
comportement très strictes à l'ump
ces disciplines fois encore pas les
attaques personnelles on participe aux
victoires de 2014 et on participe à la
définition d'une doctrine commune de
droite renouveler tout ça doit nous
permettre de vivre dans les trois
prochaines années
de manière constructive et sereine alors
si on vous demandait aujourd'hui une
définition l'ump qu'est ce que vous
diriez stores on a bien compris ce
n'était pas parti monolithique vous ne
souhaitez pas c'est quoi c'est une
réunion plusieurs chapelles c'est une
réunion peut-être d'écurie de fusion
candidat potentiel à la présidentielle
sur donc peut-être ailleurs tout pas de
camp visé un de ses programmes des
candidats
oui il vaut mieux mais c'est le
rassemblement de toutes les sensibilités
de droite la droite
l ex uni l idri autour de sensibilité
qui sont forcément différentes et modéré
sur la question toujours à l'aise dans
cette configuration là ce parce que je
refuse catégoriquement la distinction
entre une droite fréquentable endroit'
infréquentable entre une droite qui
serait humaniste sympathique ouverte
et puis une autre droite qui traiterait
des sujets difficiles comme la sécurité
comme l'immigration comme les trafics de
drogue ou toutes sortes d'autres trafics
et qui elle serait pas fréquentable moi
j'estime que la droite soit couvrir tous
les problèmes des français etc au lieu
d'aborder sa de manière idéologique
nous devons aborder ça de manière
pragmatique en nous disant quelles sont
aujourd'hui les problèmes que
rencontrent les français au quotidien
dans leur commune dans leur ville et
qu'elle seule chose que nous leur
apportons à bien sûr il ya le problème
du chômage problème numéro un
le problème de l'emploi des jeunes
problème massif essentiel nous devons
apporter les réponses mais il ya aussi
les problèmes d'immigration illégale il
ya aussi le problème du droit d'asile
qui aujourd'hui n'est pas suffisamment
contrôlé où il ya trop de demandeurs et
où les procédures sont trop longs il ya
des problèmes de sécurité sur vous
jacques c'est que nous devons à droite
traiter tous les problèmes des français
sans exclusive et sans tabou mais on
était loin de couvrir tout l'éventail de
ses expressions partie de la droite peut
se salir les mains et que vous non
justement où vous épargner
je veux pas mais pas mort je veux pas
mais panier j'estime que ce n'est pas se
salir les mains que de dire qu' il y a
un problème avec le contrôle de
l'immigration en france
j'estime que ce n'est pas se salir les
mains que de dire qu'en matière
d'augmentation des violences aux
personnes on a atteint des seuils qui
sont insupportables en france dans ma
propre circonscription dans les petites
communes rurales
il arrive maintenant qu'on règle ses
comptes à coups de kalachnikov c'est ça
la réalité de la france
et j'estime que ce problème là c'est à
la droite de le poser sur la table et
d'y apporter des réponses
un objectif d'avoir adhéré de 2 ans de 2
ans pour instruire les demandes de droit
d'asile en france alors que ça devrait
être six mois c'est un problème que vous
avez quoi le maire c'est un petit peu le
l'inventaire du quinquennat de monsieur
sarkozy s'est pas d'inventaire c'est
regarder les couverts une élection entre
autres c'est un côté tourné vers le
passé qui me plaît pas moi j'aimais pas
je regardais le passé pour mieux
préparer l'avenir est venue ne pourrait
tourner sereinement vers l'avenir
nous devons avoir aussi le courage à
droite de dire que en dix années
d'exercice du pouvoir
il ya un certain nombre de problèmes sur
lesquels nous n'avons pas apporté les
solutions que les français nous
demandait et donc nous devrons les
aborder différemment par avoir des
solutions plus efficaces et les réponses
qui marche mieux
mais est ce que l'ump ne peut paralyser
par la question lancinante du retour ont
pas de retour d'ailleurs de nicolas
sarkozy en 2015 ou 2016
en tous les cas on al'impression vous
savez pas trop sur quel pied danser
j'ai bien compris ce que vous n'êtes
dire qu'il ya des fortes personnalités
que chacun avait son caractère qu'il
devait y avoir elles sont très
différents enfin bon on sent quand même
qui manque un chef est ce que vous
diriez d'ailleurs qui manque un chef
aujourd'hui à l'ump
bon je me sens pas du tout en situation
de manque et je vais vous dire j'ai
passé cinq années formidables avec
nicolas sarkozy quatre années au
gouvernement comme les affaires
européennes ou comme mise sur la culture
formidable avec nicolas sarkozy
j'ai été très heureux avec lui sans lui
toujours très heureux maintenant
s'enfuit c'est à lui de décider mais
parce que j'ai un caractère plutôt
heureux vous savez donc il revient c'est
à lui de le décider et on doit le
laisser lire mais ce qui serait une
erreur et pour tout dire une faute de la
part de notre famille politique ce
serait de vivre dans la tente du chef en
se disant on travaille pas en attendant
qui leur est ce que ce soit au niveau de
la taille
je travaille midi et soir une erreur de
lancer un appel à nicolas sarkozy qu est
ce qu il a dit j'aimerais mais je
reviendrai que la droite aujourd'hui a
mieux à faire que de lancer des appels
ou que d'attendre que nicolas sarkozy
revienne
elle doit travailler travailler
travailler pour reconstruire une
doctrine cohérente et emporté des
victoires en 2014 est ensuite ce sens à
nicolas sarkozy laisse le prendre
librement sa décision et par définition
sa définition
sa décision sera respect certain dans
votre parti pense que monsieur sarkozy
est l'unique recours à droite vous fait
pas partie de ceux là apparemment je
pense que nous avons à construire une
alternative crédible à des socialistes
qui sont en train de planter le pays
c'est pour cela je me trouve quand même
je ne lève pas un matin j'ai
l'impression que certains se lèvent le
matin en se disant tiens ce qui a une
dépêche qui annonce le retour de sarkozy
ce qui va revenir je laisse une question
lancinante entière liberté que tous les
jeux de rôles travail est sur la même
ligne de départ
nicolas sarkozy compris selon vont là
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on a des élections
allemandes et smalling de départ mais ça
dépend quelle course vous voulez juin je
pense le 6 juin par nicolas sarkozy vous
savez je suis vais vous dire il y aura
deux présidentielles pour personne en
2017 si nous ne gagnons pas des
victoires locales en 2014 voilà ma
conviction l'art et profère avec louise
mais parce que tant que nous ne
reprenons pas des villes moyennes des
villes importantes à la gauche
nous ne pourrons pas touché suffisamment
le corps social français
pour rêver à des victoires nationales en
2017 soit par des municipales alors
quelle ville pensez vous pouvoir
reprendre à la gauche
et quelle ville pourriez vous perdre je
pense bien sûr à paris en premier lieu
amèneront prenons pareil nous
reprendrons paris avait cadré valable
jusqu'au morizet nous reprendrons paris
c'est un avis parmi d'autres qui ne
compte pas plus
autre moi je crois exactement le
contraire nathalie kosciusko morizet
était la meilleure candidate que nous
pouvons présenter elle a fait une
formidable campagne de primaire elle
l'emporté largement
elle a la dynamique pour elle et moi je
me battrai à côté d'elle comme dans
d'autres villes de france pour qu elles
l'emportent
je suis prêt à prendre ce soit tous les
paris nathalie kosciusko morizet gagnera
la capitale en mars prochain
oui vous entendu d'ailleurs il ya pas
longtemps dire que vous pariez une belle
caisse de bon vin comme vous savez que
je ne parlais général quand je pars i c
pour ne nie pas pour clermont d'accord
françois fillon a dit l'autre jour à la
télé c'était jeudi dernier il était à
des paroles et des actes sur france 2
qu'il voulait être candidat à l'elysée
par devoir et pas par envie
mais c'est suffisant ça pour gagner le
coeur des français par devoir
chacun présente ses choix politiques
comme il l'entend moi je respecte
françois fillon j'ai beaucoup d'amitié
pour lui il construit un parcours qui
est éminemment respectable et qui ne
gêne personne n'était pas la question
excusez moi mais c'est le député et mais
c est l candidat dit écoutez j'y vais
parce que bon ben je suis obligée d'y
aller c'est un devoir mais vous savez je
n'ai pas vraiment envie
est-ce que ça se fasse figure c'est une
question de sensibilité personnelle
c'est quelque chose qui engage ce qu'on
a plus profond soit ses plus profondes
convictions
donc françois fillon exprime ses
convictions de cette manière la
reconstitution respecter l ambition et
avait envie aussi
mais de toute façon je vous le redis
nous n'en sommes pas là à mon sens n'en
sommes pas là après on sait que l'église
est tout à l'heure à juste titre chacun
son caractère
parmi les responsables de l'ump qui vous
a pas échappé que le caractère de
françois fillon n'est pas le caractère
nathalie kosciusko morizet qui n'est pas
le caractère de bono le maire qui n'est
pas le caractère jean françois copé qui
n'est pas le caractère de françois
baroin ou d'autres de xavier bertrand
et c'est comme ça que c'est bien parce
que notre famille politique doit être le
reflet non seulement de la diversité des
sensibilités politiques mais aussi des
diversités des tempéraments le
tempérament ça compte en politique et
les français quand ils vous regardent
ils regardent aussi votre tempérament
quelqu'un à terre vous avez un caractère
heureux ont un caractère renfrogné vous
êtes quelqu'un tourner dans l'avenir le
passé de dynamique vous êtes plus
taux réservés et puis ensuite ils se
font leurs idées et ils votent et c'est
lui qui tranche et monsieur fillon va
bientôt lancer son club forces
républicaines est-ce qu'il s'agit d'une
ump bis il ya qu'une l'ump et pour le
coup moi je me battrai pour que nous
gardions l'ump uni capable de traiter
tous les problèmes des français et sans
qu'il y ait de concurrence extérieure
qu'est ce que ça va être on ne savait
pas mais pour moi c'est l'ump ça c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas négociable à
mes yeux je m'étais exprimé quand il ya
vu la création du groupe r ump pour dire
que je n'y étais pas favorable parce que
tout ce qui va dans ce sens de la
division ne me plaît pas je souhaite que
l'ump reste pour tous les leaders de la
droite
la référence que personne ne compte donc
forces républicaines vous préféreriez
que ça n'existe pas
chacun peut avoir son club son
association il faut encore je respecte
beaucoup
justement il y en a beaucoup ailleurs en
politique c'est normal
du moment qu'on sait où on habite et
quelle est notre famille politique l'ump
c'est notre famille politique
alors en dehors du club du prochain club
de monsieur fillon
il ya également cinq couronnes distingue
à l'ump et entre la droite forme de
guillaume pelletier puis la droite
humaniste nos jours pierre raffarin il
ya parfois des divergences massa
importante je pense à l'europe notamment
un et comment est-ce qu'on peut
organiser la diversité à l'ump son cas
c'est le parti moi je n'ai jamais été un
grand fan des courants je les dis je
pense que des courants ça plaît beaucoup
au parti socialiste
moi ça me plaît moins dans ma propre
famille politique on l'a fait très bien
ensuite la vraie question c'est comment
est ce que je suis en sont deux sujets
difficiles nous arrivons à avoir des
idées cohérente et une doctrine claire
je pense à la question européenne
il va falloir que très rapidement dans
les semaines qui viennent nous
définissions une ligne politique sur
l'europe qui soit la plus claire
possible
moi je plaide pour une autre europe je
plaide pour une intégration européenne
sur des bases différentes et je plaide
pour un certain nombre de décisions
claires vis à vis des français
prenez par exemple l'ouverture des
frontières de schengen à la bulgarie et
la roumanie en janvier 2014
je pense que c'est de la folie j'espère
que mon parti n'ait politique prend une
position claire sur ce sujet en disant
la politique de retour des roms dans
leur pays d'origine a été un échec
donc nous demandons le report de
l'ouverture des frontières de schengen à
la roumanie et la bulgarie d'un an ou de
deux ans mais pas en janvier 2014
c'est sur des questions si ça nous
devons être clairs toute dernière
question la belge
alors jean françois copé a dit et redit
qu'il n'y aurait jamais d'alliance avec
le fn mais au niveau local tentation
partout et parfois fortes de de faire
des alliances est ce que ça vous
inquiète
on voit bien qu'il peut y avoir un
risque et ce où l'armée je crois que la
position prise par tous les responsables
de l'ump sans exception elle est très
claire aucune alliance avec le front
national
et s'il devait y avoir une alliance ce
serait une exclusion immédiate d'autres
familles politiques et en cas de duel ps
front national cette dernière question
au second tour de 2014 vous appeler à
voter ps ou êtes vous aussi dans le
monde s'y colle et jean-françois que le
front républicain
je n'aime pas le front républicain parce
que je pense que nous avons des
convictions nous devons tout faire pour
ne retrouver en situation de défendre
nos idées et pas voter pour nos
adversaires
merci beaucoup et nadège a les nerfs
interne on va nous rejoindre maintenant
bruno le maire pour parler révolution
puisque c'est votre leitmotiv
voyons d'abord avec mary brémaud si vous
parvenez d'ores et déjà à lever une
armée
ne l'appelez pas brunolerouge mais tout
de même le sage député de l'eure est
bien décidé à impulser une révolution
démocratique dans l'air du temps
six propositions pour moraliser la vie
publique avec le soutien de 13
parlementaires
quand on est parlementaire il faut
démissionner la fonction publique comme
il l'a fait
tel que le fait de dire qu'il faut
limiter le nombre de mandats de
parlementaire dans le temps tel que
également de la question du nombre de
parlementaires je crois qu'il vaudrait
mieux qu'il y ait moins de
parlementaires disposant de plus de
moyens pour travailler ça aussi c'est
une disposition qui irait dans le bon
sens mais avec ce genre de disposition
pas sûr que l'ancien ministre de
l'agriculture se fasse beaucoup d'amis
au sein des assemblées
or pour gravir les échelons mieux vaut
être entouré un moment il faudra s'il
veut effectivement peser sur la suite il
faudra qu au delà d'être un homme de
débat et de dialogue
il est une structure une organisation
il est un peu un système un peu autour
de lui pour drainer les voix les
soutiens les parlementaires etc mettre
en route la machine pour peser sur celle
de l'ump
avec en ligne de mire 2010 est un défi
de taille pour celui qui apparaît
parfois pas assez à droite l'ump pas
assez animal pour la politique
est-ce qu'il est assez charnelle pour
être un leader maximo sans doute c'est
pas dans l'adn aujourd'hui la culture du
dialogue et du compromis
voilà l'adn de bruno le maire
aujourd'hui il lui faudra sans doute
forcer sa nature pour enfin s'imposer
dans l'arène ont parlé de convictions
charnel il s'agira pas de forcer ma
nature contrairement à ce que dit le
reportage il s'agira de révéler ma
nature à ce que la nature est
certainement beaucoup beaucoup plus
charnel que ce que vous pouvez penser
beaucoup plus à démontrer
non mais je pensais jamais il vous voit
tel que vous êtes le premier agriculteur
six agriculteurs ont eu la gentillesse
d'apprécier mon passage à la culture je
pense pas que ce soit pour des qualités
technocratique je crois que c'est parce
qu'ils ont vu mon attachement charnel au
monde agricole au monde paysan français
donc on force pas sa nature j'y crois
pas à ça en revanche on peut la révéler
et montrer aux gens que vous êtes un peu
différent de ce que vous pensiez vous
étiez pas qui vous avez conseillé de de
prendre le masque politique
oui mais moi je n'aime pas les masques
je crois la sincérité et ma sincérité
c'est qu'effectivement contrairement à
ce que dit votre reportage mais je vais
pas trop ça c'est eric et je suis plus
charnel que je vous plais à penser en
avant de voir
routhier ma famille je suis allé chez
lui a pas très longtemps et c'est à ses
lecteurs absolument formidable en tout
cas pour l'instant vous n'êtes pas parti
en croisade sur un sujet qui fâche parce
que la révolution démocratique la
moralisation de la vie publique c'est
plutôt un sujet qui met tout le monde
d'accord et en tout cas les français
dira même que ça frise presque la
démagogie je crois exactement l'inversé
je pense qu'il faut beaucoup de courage
pour s'aventurer sur ce sujet pourquoi
parce que j'appartiens à un groupe
parlementaire que ce coup parlementaire
il est composé de beaucoup d'amis des
gens que je respecte et pour lesquels
j'ai beaucoup d'amitié
l'immense majorité de ce groupe
parlementaire est composée de députés
qui cumule donc forcément je vais contre
eux je ne fais pas que des amis en
prenant cette décision lorsque le
fleurissement vie comme si là c'est
difficile mais je le fais par conviction
je pense très sincèrement qu'aujourd'hui
on peut plus expliquer aux français
qu'on est maire d'une ville de 100000
habitants qu'on peut être un bon maire
d'une ville de 100000 habitants et en
même temps être député je crois très
sincèrement que nous devons rompre le
lien de consanguinité entre la haute
fonction publique française et les élus
la france n'a plus vocation est dirigée
par une promotion de l'ena moi j'ai
démissionné de leur fonction publique
donc c'est du courage et je souhaite que
ça fasse partie de cette révolution
démocratique dénonce effectivement la
fameuse promotion voltaire
on est cependant quel autre pays une
autre motion du négoce réduite à 40
personnes qui dirigent tout le pays mais
franchement comment ça peut marcher
un pays c'est fait d'une diversité de
talents formidables c'est des ingénieurs
c'est des gens du privé c'est des
personnes qui ont des formations très
différente faut même mettre des artistes
si vous le souhaitez enfin c'est des
gens qui viennent de tous les horizons
pour nos supporters on se sent tous les
conditions de l'enfance dans la
promotion voltaire de l'ena hop on prend
tous les postes et puis pour les
conseillers on prend la promotion
suivante 20 ans plus tard honnêtement je
trouve pas que ce soit des visions très
moderne de la politique donc moi
j'appelle à cette révolution
vous tapez révolution démocratique point
fr vous tomber dessus
vous soutenez déjà plusieurs milliers de
français ça veut dire que ça ne prend
pas tellement pour l'instant
ça prendra le jour où le texte arrivera
au parlement parce que là il va y avoir
des débats et puis on mettra françois
hollande face à ses contradictions
c'est lui-même qui avait dit je veux
l'internation du cumul des mandats en
est ce qu'il le fera moi je lui dis
chiche mais pour l'instant un point sera
effectivement on voit les français sont
globalement pour cette moralisation de
la vie publique
mais les élus freine des quatre fers sur
le cumul des mandats sur la publication
de leur patrimoine alors ce
questionnement ils sont les mieux placés
pour réformer leur propre statut c'est
compliqué je pense que nous aurions tous
s'intéressent notamment et à la droite à
montrer aux français que nous sommes
prêts à changer nous les élus eux les
françaises ont changé on leur a demandé
de changer
l'ouvrier qui en a dit voilà ton métier
aujourd'hui est dépassée il faut que tu
prennes une nouvelle formation de
nouvelles qualifications il a changé le
fonctionnaire à qui on n'a ni du travail
et d'antennes direction elle va
fusionner rester l'horizon ils ont
changé je souhaite que les élus montrent
que eux aussi sont capables de changer
le sens de la révolution démocratique
une manière de dire aux français nous
les élus nous acceptons de changer comme
vous vous avez changé aux côtés d'anna
est ce que pour être en accord avec vous
même vous voterez le texte présenté par
le gouvernement sur la transparence de
la vie politique
non non non je voterai même contre ce
terrible mais c'est pas un premier pas
soit on fait vraiment un changement
majeur et je vote transparence totale je
vote mais la transparence à moitié a
minima qui donne à fond c'est à dire une
publication automatique avait dit les
mots ont un sens et moi je crois au sens
des mots
alors vous françois hollande avait dit
je ferai la transparence totale sur le
patrimoine des députés
je les fais moi même ensuite trois
semaines plus tard et se déjuge je dis
bien qu ils se déjugent il ne fait pas
la transparence totale
et bien moi je vote contre un président
de la république qui se déjuge et ce
sera la même chose sur le cumul des
mandats
si monsieur hollande tient parole et
qu'il fait une vraie révolution
démocratique comme celle toujours peine
2004 c'était d irrigation une
application dès 2014 comme il l'avait
promis
plus la démission de la fonction
publique quand on devient député ou
sénateur plus la réduction du nombre de
parlementaires à 400 pour les députés
plutôt que 517 comme je le propose là je
vote
si en revanche ça se limite uniquement à
une petite réforme ce cumul des mandats
applicable en 2017
je veux très con
parce que ce serait une façon de dire
non au président de la république qui ne
tient pas ses promesses sur un autre
point par exemple la tam et
l'interdiction du cumul de certaines
professions avec le statut de
parlementaire ça vous seriez pour une
limitation
non parce que je crois qu'un
parlementaire doit pouvoir continuer à
exercer un métier s'ils allaient jouer
de temps en temps pour en réguler là
dessus avec un meilleur contrôle des
conflits d'intérêts le problème c'est
que nous n'avons pas en france la
culture du contrôle du conflit
d'intérêts conflit d'intérêts n'est même
pas habitué dès son plus jeune âge on
devrait apprendre ce que c'est qu'un
conflit d'intérêts mieux être au courant
de ce que c'est et avoir un contrôle
mille fois plus strictes de contrôle du
conflit d'intérêts en tout cas il
faudrait un consensus politique autour
de ces questions n'est loin la voix
c'est moins bien on a des droits mais
c'est tous ces changements parce que moi
ce qui me préoccupe c'est que c'est la
politique qui insuffle le changement et
si les politiques ne sont pas crédibles
s'ils font l'objet d'une suspicion
permanente ce qui est le cas aujourd'hui
il ne pourra pas y avoir de changement
comme moi je veux un changement radical
pour notre pays parce que je le crois
nécessaire
je parle du premier point de départ nous
changeons d'abord le mode de
fonctionnement des élus pour qu'ils
retrouvent leur crédibilité et qu'ils
puissent lancer le changement qu'il
paraît indispensable alors deux autres
exemples de chiffres qui ont pas mal
choqué les français cette semaine tout
d'abord celle de la rémunération de
claude bartelone 70% cette rémunération
est non imposable
est-ce que là aussi il faudrait modifier
on pourrit tout ça mais vous savez si on
commence à se lancer dans la question
des rémunérations des élus d'indemnité
représentative de frais de mandat
moi je suis prête pour cette
transparence la transparence précisément
pour lever le soupçon
mais arrêtons de dire systématiquement
qu'il faut réduire le traitement de
monsieur untel ou de madame untel a un
parfum de la réduction des traitements
on finira l'imposition vous expliquer
que les parlementaires finalement
devrait travailler sans rémunération
donc moi je suis prêt la transparence
pour lever tout soupçon autres chiffres
c'est les 10000 euros par mois de frais
de primes que touchent et claude guéant
lorsqu'il était directeur de cabinet au
ministère de l'intérieur
est-ce que selon vous c'est de l'argent
des
on est dans la destination finale c'est
c'est une information de presse qui
aujourd'hui est aux mains de la justice
moi ce que je souhaite c'est que la
justice fasse toute la lumière là dessus
étrange mais je vais te tiens pas à
faire de communication par rapport à
notre tradition est commandée par bien
milliers de vases qui à le remettre à la
justice et justice on fera ce qu'elle
doit en faire et je commenterai une fois
coalition de justice sera rendue
pour le moment j'ai pas de commentaire
spécial à faire là dessus raffarin lui
s'est dit très préoccupé par cette
information ce matin il était premier
ministre un camp claude guéant était à
l'intérieur ni chacun ses déclarations
je vous dis je tant que le juge jean
stream fasse toute la lumière sur cette
affaire et ce dont je peux témoigner
comme membre de cabinet c'est que toutes
les primes que j'ai pu toucher et est
versée sur ma feuille de paye comme
n'importe quel autre monde de cabinet et
que je n'ai jamais vu circuler de
liquide dans un cabinet ministériel ya
des syndicats lé ministère de
l'intérieur qui demande à claude guéant
de rendre l'argent
laissons chacun s'exprimer sur le sujet
entre lesquels vous ne dites rien non je
n'ai pas de commentaire particulier à
faire je voudrais la moralisation et
brigitte on a une affaire mais encore
faut-il que la fin rapport elle m a dit
l'officiel affaire soit instruite qui
est des preuves tangibles que la justice
ait rendu ses décisions
je ne fait que témoigner de ce que j'ai
vécu comme membre de cabinet entre 2002
et 2007
les primes elles sont sur une feuille de
paye pas pas transparent du moment voilà
ce dont je peux témoigner encore une
question toujours dans le cadre de la
révolution démocratique est ce qui vous
apparaît possible pour un ancien chef de
l'état de faire des conférences un peu
partout dans le monde
bien payé et en même temps de continuer
à siéger au conseil constitutionnel je
crois qu'il est pas le seul
je pense qu'il n'est pas le seul à faire
des conférences très bien rémunérées
mais si on arrive à washington si on
regardait tony blair
un coup de mai et la française là encore
ce sont des décisions qui
n'appartiennent qu'à ceux qui les
prennent
nicolas sarkozy devient les différents
avis cela ne me choque absolument pas
qu'il fasse des conférences rémunéré
c'est le choix de vie qu'il a fait et il
est respectable tout en restant conseil
constitutionnel c'est normal sur son
travail au conseil constitutionnel une
leçon après la mort de clément méric le
premier jean marc ayrault l'a annoncé
tout à l'heure à l'assemblée aux
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
il va demander la dissolution des
mouvements d'extrême droite troisième
voie et jeunesse nationale
révolutionnaire est ce que vous estimez
que ce genre de dissolution c'est
réellement quelque chose donc les groupe
se reforme aussitôt après non je pense
que c'est nécessaire parce que c'est un
signal politique qu'on en voit et c'est
important d'envoyer un signal politique
tous les groupes extrémistes qui ne sont
pas les bienvenus en france et que notre
démocratie refusera la violence la
violence n'est pas une modalité
d'expression de son opinion dans une
démocratie comme la démocratie française
mais ensuite encore faut-il que les
sanctions qu'ils soient donnés sur des
sanctions exemplaires
moi ce qui me préoccupe c'est la
contradiction complète entre la fermeté
qu'affiche monsieur valls et le laxisme
dont fait preuve madame taubira vous
pouvez pas avoir un ministre de
l'intérieur mais qui ne cesse de se
hausser du col et de lever le menton et
de l'autre côté le ministre de la
justice qui l envoient des instructions
pour avoir les peines les plus légères
possible systématiquement moi j'ai
demandé une politique pénale stricte une
politique pénale qui affiche les peines
qui les donne à ceux qui les méritent et
qui ne me dise pas qu'ils ne faiblissent
pas dernière question on connaît votre
goût pour les affaires européennes au
delà de votre tropisme allemand bruno le
maire aimerait savoir si les
manifestants anti radio gagnent en
turquie votre soutien nous y lisons mon
plein soutien et pour le coup je suis
profondément préoccupés de l'évolution
de la turquie où je vois monsieur
erdogan se transformer en autocrate
nature qui mérite mieux qu'un autocrate
à sa tête et je trouve que la manière
dont les manifestants courageusement
s'exprime pour défendre leur liberté
d'expression pour défendre une certaine
idée de la turquie à laquelle je suis
attaché
la turquie laïque la turquie liban la
turquie on peut exprimer son opinion
la turquie on n'est pas enfermé on n'est
pas
soumis à des contrôles ou dépression
quand on exprime une opinion différente
de celle du pouvoir ça c'est la belle
turquie c'est celle que je défends
merci beaucoup merci perrine oui merci
monsieur est clair on va suivre dans vos
efforts pour vous présenter aux français
dans votre dimension charnelle
c'est la fin de cette édition et a très
vite à tous
pour guérir d'une maladie pour mieux
vivre les médecines naturelles séduire
venu dans l'air du temps
en une heure très le edge le carreau
tour naturel avec rolls gic total sans
réflexion ou le de la médecine mais sous
couvert de soigner autrement certaines
thérapies profitent de la faiblesse des
malades et peuvent représenter un vrai
danger sur la santé il praticiens le
fait suivant sa sensibilité pas pouvoir
déterminer au son du blocage chou fourni
des munitions en route on joue du
journalisme sénat une commission
denquête s'est emparé du sujet médecines
parallèles guérir à tout prix jeudi à 18
heures sur public sénat
bonjour à tous un lieu une histoire vous
accueille au coeur de la tour de
constance de la cité d'aigues-mortes
cette cité lieu de départ des croisades
au moyen âge
régis terre le mot est gravé dans la
pierre de cette marge elle il signifie
résister dans la langue occitane ce mot
c'est une femme qu'il aurait inscrit ici
est grave et de ses propres mains
alors cette femme que j'évoquais à
l'instant s'appelait marie durand elle a
été emprisonnée ici même là où je me
trouve pendant 38 ans de 1730 à 1768
elle n'était pas la seule puisque
d'autres femmes étaient également
emprisonnés avec elle tout pour la même
raison pour ne pas renier leur foi
protestante patrick ferrand son bonjour
vous êtes historien ici dans cette tour
de constance est ce qu'on peut dire que
c'est marie durand véritablement qui a
gravé cette inscription résister sur
cette marge est la firme est une bien
grand chose on a des présomptions très
forte pour penser que marie durand iter
mesure où de graves et ce message à la
postérité dans la mesure où c'est une
femme lettrée
c'est elle qui conduit c'est toutes ces
femmes à résister à la tentation de
l'abjuration et qui au fil des siècles
s'est présenté comme un véritable
symbole de la résistance à l'intolérance
royal alors pour quelles raisons marie
durand et l emprisonner ici même son
tour c'est d'être protestante et d'être
la soeur de pierre durand qui est un
pasteur qui est assez élégant en train
de dci de soulever à nouveau les
cévennes contre le linteau l'errance
royal donc le pouvoir essayer de faire
pression sur les familles il m'a rien
sur l'ensemble de la famille de façon à
ce que le pasteur un petit peu
qui est un personnage relativement
dangereux pour la nation enfin pour la
monarchie passe sous les verrous alors
marie durand n'était pas seul ici elle
était accompagnée entouré d'autres
femmes également prisonnière pour quelle
raison il n'y avait que des femmes ici
même dans un premier temps il a faim du
xviie siècle ce sont sur les deux
niveaux que sont incarcérés les
protestants au rez de chaussée les
femmes qu'au premier étage les eaux et
puis il se passe au début du xviiie et
le l'évasion spectaculaire d'abraham
hazell le 25 juillet 1705 peu de temps
après l'administration royale
d'aigues-mortes a décidé d'infirmer ici
dans cette tour que des femmes et
jusqu'au milieu du xviiie siècle se
seront que les femmes qui sont enfermés
donc on a du mal beaucoup de mal à
imaginer combien une vingtaine de femmes
enfermées si par moments c'est jusqu'à
50 femmes jusqu'à 50 femmes mais qui
vont être déplacés au gré des vents
forts ici petit peu de l'administration
royale
mais on a toujours au minimum une
quinzaine de femmes enfermées
quels contacts avec ces femmes
prisonnières marie durand en particulier
avec l'extérieur on est très surpris
lorsqu'on connaît par exemple la
correspondance de marie durand il ya de
nombreuses lettres qui atteste de cette
vie si en effet marc durand et se
présente comme l'intermédiaire de ses
compagnes d'infortuné c'est elle qui va
par exemple ceux proposés à
l'administration pour essayer
d'améliorer la condition des autres
femmes éleva étant donné qu'elle
électrique elle sait écrire faire
régulièrement la liste de ses compagnes
d'infortuné de façon à pouvoir établir
une certaine de comment dire
démographique entre guillemets de des
habitantes de cette tour et au delà
encore marie durand va s'adresser à tous
et kg et puissances étrangères
susceptibles d'influer au moins sur la
politique royale
et si ce n'est à un flux le sur cette
politique
au moins on veut donner quelques
subsides pour que les conditions de vie
de ces pauvres femmes soient améliorés
alors nous sommes au troisième étage de
cette tour de constance au dessus de
nous y ait une terrasse ou de temps en
temps marie durand et les autres
prisonnières avait l'occasion d'aller
avec autorisation bien sûr pour voir le
paysage et respire et surtout un petit
air de liberté je propose d'y aller tout
de suite de refaire ensemble leur chemin
voilà nous sommes sur cette terrasse on
voit une ville extraordinaire sur toute
cette camargue évidemment aigues-mortes
derrière nous alors pourquoi marie
durand été libéré au bout de toutes ces
années bien en 1768 nouveau gouverneur
de la mauvaise langue d'oc
le prince
décidé d'entreprendre la tournée de ses
prisons et se retrouve avec mortes et où
l'attendait un spectacle assez différent
puisque restent enfermés dans des
conditions de santé très critique
quatorze femmes toutes très âgées
parfois veulent notamment des conditions
de vie qu'elle est privée parfois aussi
un peu de fond et le cross de nouveau va
s'attacher à la libération de ces femmes
regarder derrière moi cette barre noire
c'est la barre des cévennes à une
centaine de kilomètres du nous sommes
ici avec morte
on y distingue ray presque les villages
où se sont réfugiés les protestants
après la révocation de l'édit de nantes
parmi ceux ci deux villages de mialet
presque le centre de cette terre
protestante cévenol à mialet se trouve
un musée tout à fait particulier le
musée du désert que nous allons visiter
ensemble